hello freak [ __ ] by the year 2040
it's estimated at a hundred percent of
the federal federal budget will go
towards Medicare and Medicaid expenses
leaving nothing for anything else
military 21 with 2040 why is talking
about our lifetimes that's real that's
real that's if if health care spending
continues to increase at its current
pace
that's insane you're right that does not
mean this is why the Department of
Defense has has named health care as an
existential threat to this country just
like you know nuclear war or any other
military threat they've named chronic
disease as an existential threat that
could actually you know threaten our
survival as a nation Wow whoever thought
of it that way
who could have ever imagined that
literally all of our budget would go to
takin care of people's health by 2040
yeah that's not long it's not long in 22
lemme let me give you a few examples
just to you know to make this more clear
so the cost of treating a patient with
type 2 diabetes is estimated to be
$14,000 a year okay so we know now that
a hundred million Americans that's like
a third of the population have either
pre-diabetes or type 2 diabetes what
yeah wait a minute CDC just published
these numbers 100 million Americans yeah
it's insane pre-diabetes or type 2
diabetes one-third one-third and that is
crime having a hard time what if you had
just asked me like what percentage of
Americans have diabetes I probably said
like 4% yeah who actually have type 2
diabetes is lower it but I said
pre-diabetes or type 2 days are on their
way
yeah so so here a couple other stats 88
percent of people who have pre-diabetes
don't know that they have it and in the
80% and the average amount of time it
takes for someone to progress from
pre-diabetes to full-fledged type 2
diabetes is just five years
Wow so let's go back to that number
$14,000 a year to treat a single patient
with type 2 diabetes
imagine someone gets diagnosed at age 40
which is totally possible I mean now
even eight-year-old kids are being
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes and
imagine that person lives another 45
years which is also feasible because we
have these and one of the amazing things
about conventional medicine and so the
technologies that keep us alive probably
a lot longer
you know then we should be so let's say
that person lives forty five years we
spend $13,000 a year fourteen thousand
dollars a year treating that person
that's six hundred and thirty thousand
dollars to treat one patient with one
disease over that patients you know
remaining lifetime now if you start
doing some math and you assume you know
even 50 million people with diabetes
times six hundred and thirty thousand
dollars you get a number with so many
zeros after it I don't even know what it
is it's like a Google or a googolplex or
something so this is why we're we're
facing this threat and this is why I
wrote the book it's like I people aren't
aware that we're at this point where you
know like one in two Americans now has a
chronic disease one in four have
multiple one in two Americans has a
chronic disease one and two one in four
have multiple chronic diseases and I
know you're a parent so and I am to 30%
almost of kids now have a chronic
disease and that's up from just 13% in
1994 so there's been more than a
doubling of kids with chronic disease in
less than 25 years how is that pot what
has changed in the American diet are you
tributing it to the American American
all effects all of the above so I would
say it's the diet it's an increase in
sedentary activity you know like sitting
for very long periods not moving around
not enough exposure to artificial or not
exposure to bright to natural light too
much exposure to artificial light not
enough sleep you know so all these
things come together and now we've got a
nation of people with chronic disease
chronic disease is bankrupting our
country and it's extremely difficult to
treat it lasts for a lifetime and our
only hope actually of dealing with this
problem and surviving as a country as a
nation is to figure out a way to prevent
and reverse disease instead of just
suppressing symptoms and putting
band-aids on it which is what our
current conventional medical system does
you really scared me with that diabetes
number that that's really freaking out I
can't believe that well what he pulled
up Jane more than a hundred million
Americans have diabetes or its precursor
staggering CDC report reveals and this
is just from July yeah Wow in 2015 least
1.5 million new cases were diagnosed in
people over 18 now a third of the US
population has diabetes the CDC just
updated to obesity statistics now 40
percent of US adults are obese oh my god
forty percent four and ten not just
overweight obese and 40 percent 40
percent and almost 20 percent of
adolescents are now obese now how are
they basing this by those body standards
body mass index yeah but I'm a beast
yeah it's not doctors work it's not
perfect but it's not so so imperfect
that it's you know we're talking about a
20 percent difference look up body mass
index five foot eight 200 pounds I think
I'm like dying like if you look at the
body mass index I think I'm like of
terrible health but all you have to do
is go to an air you know I just flew
down here right now you sit in an
airport and you look around yeah you
know that statistics are crap but
there's also a lot of people that lift
weights like there's a lot of people
that are bigger I would like to know
what the you know what am i obese
yeah I'm obese come on damn that come on
that I mean look it's just not real
that's not real it's not that well I
don't know I think that statistic I mean
do you think out of ten people that you
see on the street are for obese well if
I'm obese now I know that I'm obese all
right according to that well you gotta
throw that thing out the window that's
not a good metric
it's not a perfect metric but they have
done studies where they have counted for
that and they they do you do see some
variation but you're you're not the norm
you're not you and you're you're not
you're an outlier I'm aware of that but
I think there's probably got to be quite
a few outliers out there there are quite
a few but not enough more today I never
not enough to change that statistic in a
really meaningful way it's not gonna you
know there aren't 20% of you you know
it's not gonna drop that from 40 percent
to 20 percent
so maybe 40 to 35 is that reasonable
still a lot yeah that's I would say
maybe 40 to 39 or 30 years Jesus yeah so
so so here's the deal you know we can't
it doesn't matter who so that the whole
recent health care debate with you know
Affordable Care Act and and then the
current administration suggesting
something different that a whole
discussion revolved around how we're
gonna pay for health care you know
insurance insurance but we have to
understand that health insurance is not
the same thing as health care right it's
a method is a method of paying for
health care and my key point in the book
is it doesn't matter what method of
health that we use to pay for health
care whether it's the government whether
it's corporations or whether it's
individuals there is no method that's
sustainable in the face of the rising
rates of chronic disease that we're
seeing yeah there's there's nothing
really fascinating is I am pretty aware
of this stuff and I didn't know what
you're telling me
yeah and I'm stunned I'm stunned at the
number of people with chronic disease
and I'm stunned at the number of people
that are either pre-diabetic or diabetic
I really don't know how to digest that
yeah that's that's horrific and that
could be attributed almost entirely to
diet in a lecture it's a preventable
disease that's that that's the crazy
thing type 2 diabetes is a fully
preventable condition and type 1
diabetes varies in what way yeah that's
it's an autoimmune condition and it's
strongly genetically mediated
so it's which means that it doesn't you
know necessarily mean that if you have
the genes you're gonna get the disease
but there's you know 50% of the risk I
think is the statistics that I've seen
of type 1 diabetes is genetic whereas we
know now that 85% of the risk of disease
in general comes down to environmental
and behavioral factors behavioral
meaning you diet yeah
[Applause]
[Music]